yes I'm super fired up because in this
video I'm gonna be sharing a YouTube
formula that changed my channel for the
better but I got a question for you what
if there was a formula that could
predict your future I really believe
that there is it's called the
e2e ratio but before we get into that I
want to shout out today's video it's
sponsored by vidiq.com forward slash
think a little bit more on vid IQ later
and as we get into this let's look at
some recent stats on how people are
spending their time and their money that
actually lay a foundation for today's
topic did you know that the average
person spends three hours and 15 minutes
per day on their phone how much time do
you spend a day on your phone actually
when you look at the stats for like gen
Z you're seeing more like eight or nine
hours per day on the phone okay what
else can we learn well
um this one shocked me uh USA Today
revealed that the average American
spends almost eighteen thousand dollars
a year on
non-essentials man that's a lot of money
if you're like Sean I don't have money I
need money well there's probably some
money to be found diverted from one area
in your life to another it's kind of
fascinating and then the typical
American views just around three hours
of TV every single day so when you add
up the phone and then you add up the TV
and then you add up some of the other
things that we're seeing for example
gaming and maybe you game maybe you
don't let me know if you do as a dad of
two boys now it's been a minute since
I've been I was uh deep in gaming but
I've been there in a little bit of last
of us too a little bit of Final Fantasy
remake a little bit of uh Last of Us won
Uncharted Four but listen to this 15
hours per week is what the average gamer
in America is spending how about
watching sports not playing sports
watching sports four hours a week how
about social media 17 hours a week and
these are averages and then how about
commuting well Sean I got a commute fair
enough but like time on the road and
what are you doing if you do need to
commute to work that's five hours a week
that the average person spends commuting
so why do I bring all this up well it
brings us to this formula that can
change your life I know it did mine and
it's the e2e ratio the E to e ratio is
the amount of time and money a person
spends on entertain attainment versus
education and this formula changed my
life as it pertains to YouTube because
when you start a YouTube channel you got
to learn a lot of skills you got to
learn a lot of competencies you got to
learn new things and the e2e ratio is
one of the things that's holding the
majority of people back but it's one of
the bigger biggest opportunities to
actually take a radical Leap Forward now
this was popularized by Brian Tracy
who's a sales expert business Expert and
according to Brian Tracy the average
person spends 50 minutes on
entertainment for every one minute spent
on education and personal growth what is
your
e2e ratio I'd love to know in the
comments I'd love to know in the chat
and ultimately
this is so fascinating to me because
again it's a ratio like for every dollar
I spend on entertainment I only I don't
spend any money on on education or for
every you know for every fifty dollars
for every 50 minutes someone spends on
entertainment they're only spending one
minute and one dollar on personal growth
and so when we start to flip this ratio
I think everything can change and you
know this really uh profound if I think
about my journey you know in 2015 I was
living in Irvine California at an
apartment complex I was a campus pastor
of a church and I was wanting to build
my side hustle and I know if you watch
the think media podcast you watch the
coffee with Channel show then you might
be in a season where you want to do
YouTube full-time you want to build an
online business you want to build
passive income you want to create
Freedom away from a corporate job that
you have to commute to and so I was in a
situation where I was enjoying what I
was doing but I had a dream of also
doing YouTube tube and I had a dream of
having a life in a business you know
more on my own terms and I was living at
that time no kids with my wife Sonia and
our two dogs Sophie and Rosie this was
our a thousand square foot apartment and
this was my home office and I think
about what was it that I was doing then
and even before then that led to where
things are today what was the the shift
what was a major formula and I know you
might have thought well Sean but don't
don't I need to have like the best
videos possible well absolutely don't I
need to have good thumbnails and titles
and all the YouTube tactics we're sure
well how do you learn all that stuff and
how do you learn this stuff that's also
behind the scenes of YouTube how do you
learn about online business how do you
ultimately figure out psychology and
marketing and positioning of your brand
and figuring out your Niche how do you
figure out all those nuances well if
your e to e ratio is messed up and then
with all of the time that you have
you're spending a ton on entertainment
and very little on education and for a
majority of people you're spending a ton
of money average American 18 000 a year
on non-essentials on things that don't
matter as opposed to new skill sets new
belief systems new mindsets investing in
education well that was the big shift
for me because I mean you could see here
I got my pile of books uh behind me and
one of the habits and practices is I
would go to our local
um what do you call it like gym at Los
Olivos apartment complex and I would hit
the gym with some headphones in and I'd
be listening to podcasts I would be
reading books taking notes I was
purchasing online courses and when I
think about my e2e ratio and when I
started to understand this and I started
to shift it I wasn't watching a ton of
TV or shows or streaming uh content at
the time I wasn't gaming at the time and
as a result I was able to see a
significant shift and this was 2015 or
so and now since that time you fast
forward to today and it's like one gold
play button three silver play buttons
across four different YouTube channels
we've built a team here at think media
of about 30 people counting the
different contractors we work with
building a family trying to figure out
how to run a business and run a family
man you needed some education if you're
going to figure out how to do that like
it's a hard thing to juggle all of that
and also helping so many students
succeed and having like the leading
YouTube education program in the world
like how did that happen it's got to be
you got to flip your e2e ratio and if
there's one formula that I really think
could impact your life and your future
it's your e ratio and so this is the
coffee with candle show
what we do is we're going to do a
coaching with a couple guests here in a
second I'll also take your questions but
I'm curious if you could be honest with
me what's your e to e ratio like what
where are you at with uh how much
entertainment you're consuming per week
and where are you at with how much
education you're consuming per week
maybe even a better question
what's your credit card statement say
about your e to e ratio how much money
are you investing in learning new
competencies learning new skills
building your network building your
network of wisdom
who are you getting connected to that
you can DM or call or message or reach
out to or a group you're a part of where
when you get stuck or you have a problem
one of the things I realized is like I
don't even have to have the answer to
problems I just need to be connected to
a network that does
and so the stronger I build my network
or the communities that I'm a part of if
I get stuck I could assess my network
hey what'd you do when you got here and
if you could get a feedback loop well
that takes money invested perhaps not in
as much entertainment but is in more of
Education my e to e 2 to 20. I love it
Horan I'm not sure which is which is
entertainment that first one is about
two on entertainment 20 in education uh
I can predict your future my friend I
think that's going to be pretty amazing
Motif Studio says my e to e ratio
shifted anything I'm now trimming down
um my education I'm a wild consumer of
Education I like it okay you're trimming
it down a little bit I play the piano so
it's a huge part of my uh enter payment
I love it thanks for sharing so so what
is your e2e ratio I spent about two to
three hours every morning
um on YouTube VRA and trying to learn
more about Facebook funnels it's really
smart
um it's a game now however I listen to
uh talks about it with uh how to's we're
trying to figure it out awesome thank
you so much for sharing so what is your
e2e ratio and I know I'm kind of
preaching in the choir because if you're
watching coffee with candle if you're
subscribed to the think media podcast
Channel a lot of people here you're
probably already a part of the era fam
the reason your life is Shifting the
reason probably you're on an entirely
different path is because you have
shifted those numbers but at the
beginning of this video it's kind of
shocking that there's we have a lot more
time that we realize
we got a lot more uh you know
opportunities on our schedule then we
realize if you do the math when you add
up the TV and the social media and the
phones and the sports and so I get the
objection you might be like Sean relax
though bro I mean life's about having
fun life's about entertainment life's
about like and I get it you gotta unwind
you got to relax but there's something
powerful especially when it comes to the
law of sacrifice that you got to give up
to go up
and I've learned that the people that
are willing to give up a lot of times
Leisure and entertainment just for a
season a season might be a few years but
if you're willing to give up what the
majority of people won't sacrifice you
can get so much further ahead as you
invest your time your energy and your
money into education for me that's look
like purchasing online courses and
purchasing books and purchasing tickets
and purchasing
um tickets to like an event a business
event or a marketing event
um purchasing them the airline tickets
and the investment of the time and the
energy to go there that's also it has to
be a vision that my wife and I share
where she is bought into the idea that
like this is something that matters that
investing in ourselves and in our
learning in our education is the best
investment that we can ever make and it
has the highest returns and I want to
encourage you for you your family people
you know maybe share the e2e ratio with
them because if you really want to make
a significant change in your life I
think it can start by making a
significant change to your e to e ratio
and so um if you got any questions shout
me out four question marks before and
after your question and uh let me know
are you challenged today are you
inspired do you go man I'm good my e2e
ratio is looking good right now
um and I am dialed in as it pertains to
that let me know what your thought is I
love this quote from Dave Ramsey I see
you sharing it here Dave Ramsey taught
me about sacrificing but oh brother when
you are done exactly and Dave's quote is
if you want to live like no one else
um if you live today like no one else in
the future you'll be able to live and
give like no one else so it's about
living an uncommon life it's about
living something that it's about maybe
being different than the majority
but as a result of living an unusual
life it can lead to getting unusual
results
um shout out to vid IQ before we get
into our q a and our coaching for today
this is the coffee with Channel show and
uh our sponsor of today's episode is the
um is vid IQ one of the cool things by
the way about vid IQ
is that there is actual educational
opportunities inside of vid IQ my slides
don't work currently but uh you know
we're doing our best out here and um
seeing if we can get these to load there
they are vidiq.com forward slash think
you're actually able to get a 30-day
trial of it iq's boost plan for just one
dollar but I do want to show you
something really cool here and um along
with lots what vid IQ is if you've never
heard about it before is a suite of
tools that include keyword research and
daily video ideas and all that kind of
stuff but one of the tools that vidiq
has is now their personal AI coach and
when you sign up using our link that
iq.com forward slash think you can get a
trial of the Boost plan which gives you
access to the advanced level of the AI
coach well what does advanced mean see
there's the basic and there's the
advance and the advance is personalized
to you they will audit your channel they
give you Channel insights so I can click
this little any of the prompts that has
a little Diamond next to it I can click
that and it will give me ideas
personalized based on vid IQ analyzing
the content on my channel Kyle's in the
back end of our uh he's our producer of
the think media channel and so these are
some videos that we should should grab
right now I love this first one so these
are some they're they're handing us this
video idea coming out of in
um AI that is connected to the channel
top five camera accessories every
YouTuber needs a comprehensive review of
essential camera accessories for Content
creators focusing on affordability and
functionality thumbnail a collage of
five accessories kind of cool so it's
actually like giving you the whole
um target audience even the video length
10 to 12 minutes okay what are we
shooting for how to edit videos like a
pro tips and tricks The Ultimate Guide
to YouTube St SEO boosts your views that
would be actually a very powerful video
I have a lot to say on that in a 2023
world
and so Additionally you could also say
uh how do I get more views and this
again is not just a general question
because when you think about YouTube
content one of the challenges about
generic questions is even if I was
helping you I don't have the context of
your channel like on coffee with Channel
we're about to do two coaching sessions
those are powerful because there's more
context
the cool thing about this tool though is
if you tap into the Boost plan on vid IQ
the context is the AI coach can see your
channel so it's actually going to be
giving you essentially coaching that is
based on your channel so it's going to
talk about this is very interesting so
your primary audience is male 18 to 34.
and that's true we have about 80 male
viewership on our Channel shout out to
all the females uh strong here live on
uh coffee with camera by the way this is
connected I'm on think media podcast
with coffee with Channel right now but
this is connected to
um uh it's connected to both but we're
on our main channel here with his data
U.S India and UK our biggest three uh to
cater to this demographic focus on
content that addresses their interests
and needs and so I don't know the last
time you were thinking about the age
demographic you're going after or the
regions but it's going to be pulling
this data and contextualizing it in a
simple form for you based on your top
performing video videos here's some
video ideas that could resonate 10
YouTube algorithm secrets you need to
know it's a fire video idea The Ultimate
Guide to video editing software for
beginners how to create engaging content
on a budget
very cool stuff and so I you can see
this is you know super powerful you can
use it as much as you want whenever you
want when you are in the vid IQ boost
plan so if you go to fit iq.com forward
slash thing for just a dollar you could
try this whole thing out for 30 days and
so that link is in the description
um definitely check that out and if
you're new to the show
coffee with candle is where we have uh
content up front with one training it's
kind of an idea for you something that's
actionable today we're talking about the
E to e ratio and how it could change
your life and then we we drink coffee
together today's video uh I'm sipping
some uh black and white coffee the
future is this coffee uh hazy IPA there
we go Nice Shot
um this is for Curious coffee lovers
um definitely a unique blend I'm sipping
um
some black coffee over here what are you
drinking
let me know not every day do I have
coffee on the coffee with candle
show but today I do and we're going to
get into our first coaching session
right after this
[Music]
all right welcome back to the coffee
with candle show today we have Audrey's
little farm coming on the show and uh
we're going to be doing some q a Audrey
welcome to coffee with Channel thank you
um so tell us a little bit about your
channel how long have you been on
YouTube and uh let us know what you've
been up to
um so my channel is Audrey's little farm
and I teach about gardening and raising
chickens mostly for the beginner
chicken keeper beginner Gardener
um I do go a little bit more in depth
but majority of audiences beginners for
sure and um so I started for the past
two years I've been pretty serious on
YouTube I would say like in the last
years when I have more dove into
um trying to grow the channel but I
started a Blog in 2018 and that became
my full-time income and then that's when
I started doing YouTube as well
oh that's amazing okay so you're still
doing the blog yep so that kind of is
running on autopilot right now and my
focus has been YouTube trying to learn
how to grow that
gotcha okay
awesome
um so fired up to have you here and what
is uh a question that you have today
with on YouTube is learning how to sell
I feel like I sell well but I don't sell
often and I don't really sell
intentionally I brought up a few stats
just to give you like a background so
one of my main products is a Zone 9B
Gardening Guide which is the zone that I
live in and that's a huge audience of
mine because they talk a lot about the
Zone specific gardening and so I have
that guide and I pitched it the very
first time I think I pitched it on
YouTube was in January of 2022 and since
then
um I pitch it here and there but it
mostly is just coming up in like Google
search results the same few videos and I
get a five percent conversion rate and
I've made a little under 8 000 in the
last year on that guide
so and I was just looking Zone nine
Zone but zero nine gardening is
essentially the same but
um like Florida Texas Arizona California
I'm in California but I have people in
all of those states that follow me that
will that could use the guide
okay gotcha and so and the way you get
to it is shop how do you get to the
guide
um channels
videos that are about Zone I think on my
actual homepage I have a playlist that's
all about Zone nine so it's not in every
video it's just the ones related to zo9
so on my actual home
page uh so that one right there would
have it so that very top link goes to
the sales page and so that sales page
right now is converting at five percent
and that's just pretty much from Google
search people or you know I pitch it
casually in the videos but I'm not
really pitching the guide necessarily
and um so
am I just looking in July in July I
actually didn't even do one video I
don't think that mentioned the guide but
just from people finding me through
search
um it was a 3.8 conversion rate on that
sales page and made a little under 500.
yeah that's great and so the question is
how could we increase sales and maybe
even a little bit of the sales
communication and sales mindset is in
terms of incorporating that on YouTube
right
I love it so I mean there are a couple
things I think my first thought is
um
mindset stuff as it pertains to sales
you know sales that number one I think
there's like one percent of the
population that actually likes sales and
typically it sounds like kind of a joke
but typically there's like something
wrong with them they're typically like
narcissists so there's something like
you get into psychology like the way
their brain is wired like the average
person kind of hates sales unless
they're wired a certain way so many
people watching this probably feel the
same way I don't want to be the used car
salesman I don't want to sell I just
want to be creative and I hope my stuff
just sells so it actually is I think
very important that we invest time even
thinking of our e2e ratio in consuming
sales material that can help shift our
mindset from
compassionate people that we resonate
with that share similar values
I've done that over the years and
there's been there's been anchored
mindsets
which I know we should talk about
tactics but it really does start with
our thinking that have helped me for
example to sell is to serve that
actually when we have a product that can
change someone's life get them better
results when you can connect I'm sure
the Zone uh 9B gardening materials to
how that's going to have people
literally be more fruitful if they're
going to sell produce like make more
money like it's an exchange of value
another mindset is your income is
directly correlated to the amount of
value you add to the marketplace and
when you have something value a sales
situation is simply exchanging something
for money in this case and what you give
them if it's more valuable than the
money that they give you
then ultimately it's a bigger win for
the person that you're serving and so if
you can position your your marketing and
your products even correlating it in
sales to kind of features and benefits
we want to have just unwavering
confidence that we should sell that it's
our ethical duty to sell because you
have information that other people don't
know and they need to know that
information they could either be more
fruitful they can make more money they
get more abundance and so it then
becomes adopting the mindset of like
it's my ethical responsibility to figure
out how to ethically persuade the right
people
because
if they don't buy this pop product it's
either because it's they're they don't
even they're not in zone 9B well you
would never sell it to those people they
also don't want to take action well
great they shouldn't sell that to them
either but if they're at all interested
and you know that if they don't just buy
it but implement it it will benefit them
and that what they're getting is worth
more than the money they're paying you
I'm just trying to kind of lay a
foundation of some of the mindsets in
terms of why you should perhaps even be
louder about it and one other
interesting
um caveat would be you know if I even
the Bible's a big deal for me my faith
and I'm a Christian and so some people
think well you know but sales like would
that even be in the Bible would that
even be just kind of seems weird does it
seem like the Christian thing to do well
it's actually completely a myth it's
actually sales is not just a good idea
it's a god idea there's a proverb that
says cursed is the person who withholds
grain which is interesting that it's an
agriculture illustration when they have
grain to meet someone's need essentially
so and it says cells that curse is the
person who doesn't sell their grain as
if we have something that can benefit
others and it doesn't say that we should
give it away it says curse the person
who doesn't sell grain to those in need
and if you kind of take that back you
think about the story of Joseph with
what you know people watching this
whatever their backgrounds and beliefs
it's a very powerful Old Testament story
in Genesis where for seven years Joseph
stored up grain and then when a famine
hit it doesn't say he gave it away
there's a lot of people in the world
that are like we should just give
everything away what's fascinating is he
didn't give it away he sold it and he
first sold it for money then he started
trading it for land and for livestock
and this was a god idea as a way of he
actually saved a nation he saves Egypt a
couple things one because he took seven
years to save up grain this makes me
think about all the Blood Sweat and
Tears you've put in to learn this master
this do this you probably aren't even
charging enough that would be as we
think about these mindsets that could
help us even think that it should
probably be more than 37 like it should
probably be 97 197 you start thinking
about what is the value of what you have
how can you communicate the value of
what you have to the people that you're
serving and then have that boldness and
that confidence so those are a few
things that I think are fascinating even
like the biblical Theology of of sales
and then finally
um I think that the last thing that can
happen though is inevitably if you get
louder and if you get bolder
there's still as soon as you start to
sell there's pushback
and sometimes the fear we have is the
more we talk about on YouTube or the
more we talk about it on social media
there's we may experience less friction
or negative comments or whatever if we
don't sell something
um and because there can be some people
that have the mentality that like
everything should be free or whatever
and so this is why I think it's so
important that we develop the mindset
and belief system that Brick by Brick on
Truth ethics integrity
allows us to have the resilience to be
okay with that like it allows us to like
not just get louder get clearer not
pushy but louder in your videos more
articulate and specific in your videos
about educating people and pointing
people to to this place where you're
make you're you're offering this thing
and then knowing ahead of time though
that typically the louder you get the
more pushback you will get But
ultimately that just comes with the
territory and I like to have a view of
empathy because even you know for
example you know you're a member of era
we give away a lot of free content but
we also charge for a course and there's
five percent of people that just are
really upset about that anyone who's
been in VRA sees the value of it and
there's the whole structure of money
back guarantee and all this other stuff
that we do just so we can be in
integrity and ethics but myself and the
entire think media team for sure we get
whether it's an email or comments and
it's never that many but it can feel
like a lot because if you like to be
liked and we're afraid of other people's
opinions or just sensitive to other
people's opinions I'm just like oh yeah
you know somebody sends you an email
like how dare you charge for this you're
like because like Joseph I spent seven
years more than that Blood Sweat and
Tears learning this stuff testing this
stuff building this stuff I've made a
program that is more valuable for the
around a thousand dollars which is our
special offer right now the VRA costs
like I think about I'm like why aren't
you complaining about college it costs
fifty thousand dollars a year to go get
a digital marketing degree at a
community college right now not even a
degree just a year of classes Americans
spend eighteen thousand dollars on
non-essentials why are you and it's
because of money mindsets typically but
all that to say is having the empathy
um for the pushback you may get being
okay with that if you ultimately want to
make more sales now I want to talk about
tactics second but I love some feedback
any thoughts on money mindsets or sales
mindsets was any of that helpful in
regards to maybe how loud or how bold
you are in your videos about sales
yeah that was super helpful and I love
the um well the mindsets and then I also
love like the stories of the Bible
because that's like one of the reasons
why I love fall on YouTube I love the
Christian or the shared Faith
um and so that was like really cool
stories but um I definitely think I
could tell like as you're talking to me
that I'm like I definitely don't sell
enough because I'm worried of like I
don't want all my videos to seem like a
sales video so then I rarely pitch it
but when I do pitch it does well and so
it's just like like you're saying the
more I talk about it and the louder I
get you'll get pushed back but I would
also be way more profitable
I love it so let's talk a little bit of
tactics part two if you're getting value
too and watching this smash like and to
be to give exact chapter in verse
proverbs 11 26 people curse those who
hoard grain but they pray God's blessing
on the one who is willing to sell and so
there's something powerful
um and a couple other things you know
when we pay we pay attention and the
transformations in the transaction a lot
of times we don't value things that are
free
um we download a lot of things that are
free and so we get when we invest in
something and that also could lead to
maybe more offers that you have
um other things that you develop that
could be connected to you raising your
price because if you think about you're
an ideal customer that maybe could learn
from all of the hard work and experience
and things you've learned and what
transformation you could ultimately
um you know connect for them like some
people might think it'd be outrageous to
to pay you ten thousand dollars to coach
them but not really if if it's at
farmers markets or the way that they
sell produce or their Garden if you can
then just say Well yeah if if I actually
walk people through the what I know I
could produce twenty thousand dollars of
value well then that would be an
incredibly Fair transaction more than
fair they would have doubled their
investment if you could if you could
increase someone's business or whatever
it is
um by you could double it or triple it
then you start you know kind of
reframing some of those things the um
tactics what I would encourage is
yes talk about it more and there's a
couple things there's there's two things
number one is actually I learned this
from Celine Johnson it's funny as we're
talking about uh uh Audrey's little farm
um
is this concept of actually called
seating sometimes you don't have to sell
like overtly but you can do what's
called seating and seeding would simply
be like not actually making an offer but
talking about your product a little bit
more like you may just say one of the
things that I talk about in my zone 9B
vegetable Gardening Guide is and you
talk about the importance of having a
planner or you talk about some of the
aspects of what's inside of that and I
would say that you could it's not always
like overt call to action Link in the
description or something like that but
and you probably noticed me doing this
or perhaps maybe you do maybe don't but
maybe I'm talking about YouTube Secrets
like I don't I'm not saying go buy the
book but I'll hold the book up and I
might say you know one of the things
that I talk about in YouTube Secrets
second edition and so I see that this is
probably digital right your product's
digital yeah but you could print it out
like do you have a physical version
um I do so I printed it out and put in a
binder so in all my videos that's
actually pretty much how I do it so I
don't say like all I'm talking about is
my guide I'll give you know like
zone 9 tips for March and then like I'll
give a few tips and be like but also in
my guide right here which is printed off
um you can see like the exact dates that
you need blah blah blah and so I do like
what you just did with the book I like
hold it up and then
um and that seems like that's why I
think it sells good just kind of on
autopilot but obviously but then I feel
like um
I feel like I could probably actually do
that with other products I have in all
my other gardening videos that are not
I just kind of thought of that out loud
because I have a more in general
Gardening Guide that's for other
gardeners and um maybe like in my other
gardening videos I could do the same
similar thing
are you also building an email list yeah
right now it's about 35 000 people
how often do you email the list uh
usually every other day okay great and
so do you see a lot of sales coming from
email
um yes trip by ourselves
um like on a daily basis that's what so
people find me through YouTube and then
but mainly through the blog and then
that's kind of just a I have some
funnels that are just in place so that's
kind of an evergreen autopilot thing but
I do like I'll physically email like
real broadcast sorry broadcast every
other day but then I have my evergreen
funnels that they go through
value-based emails yeah yep
um I do so like right away they go to a
tripwire when they sign up for my email
list and that's where majority of sales
come through I would say like 70 of the
sales just go through like tripwire
sales right off the bat and then
supplier that's tripwire be a low ticket
offer before they bought anything yep so
they um I
free I
have been keeping in a
before gardeners and so then the chicken
keeping people go to a tripwire page for
my ebook that's offered at nine dollars
which is that one that you have pulled
up and then um I have my vegetable
Gardening Guide that like in general
gardeners go to and that's I think a
9 or 13 offer the tripwire cost and then
the Zone 9B guide is split into just
like the first chunk of it which is
which is just a planting schedule not
all of the tactics and that sells for
eight but they can upgrade for 19. are
you when doing broadcast emails are you
making more offers in email though
um yes so I do I try to do a like actual
flash sale to my email list every other
week cool and those do pretty well and
do you all do you do you kind of use PS
a lot yeah I just started actually doing
like in every email now that I send a PS
of like ways that I can help and the
first two is like subscribe to YouTube
that's where I'm most active right now
yes um follow me on Instagram or head to
my shop and check out the digital
products I have which I also have a
membership so that's now been in my PS2
beautiful okay I mean one too just want
to acknowledge like you're clearly uh
a leader a learner and doing so many
best practices and so that's really
inspiring and this in general is one of
the benefits of this show is there's so
much you can learn coffee with candle
family from the execution uh here also I
mean it would seem you're making you're
doing this full-time under 10 000
subscribers
yes
um and you have a Blog as well yes so
the blog last year
this year listen I think last September
is when I became
monetized so not quite a year but um
before that I was making affiliate
revenue and product sales through
YouTube but just not very much but my
blog just all on its own was doing
um a full-time income so then that's
when I dove into YouTube
um and I guess that's been I feel like I
have a good General understanding of
sales and I do well at it in my email
marketing and on the blog side but for
YouTube I guess I've been in that like
weird mindset of trying to grow it
without selling too much because I want
the channel to grow but I've been
selling some so I guess what is the good
right should I be mentioning something
in every video or is there a ratio like
well I think so uh
uh if then we then turn our attention uh
finally as we land the plane to
YouTube
um when was the last time you made Zone
9B I know you have a whole playlist when
was the last time you made Zone 9B
videos
um in June so um if you go to if you
click on home of my channel and I have a
like a whole right at the top I have
that monthly gardening tips and tasks
and I started doing that in February I
guess I missed July because we were out
of town quite a bit but um March April
May June I did one for each month and
those are the last ones I did specific
to the Zone nine what else around Zone
nine
um and you're so zone 9 is the main
offer that is the deepest offer you have
for people basically here
um yeah so I have um this majority of my
audience is zo9 I have a
um
blog post on Google that ranks like top
one to three always on Google and that's
how people majority of people find me
and so I would say 80 of my audience is
just already Zone nine and so that's my
main offer as far as like what I'm
trying to pitch the most often which
makes sense because I like talking about
an area where I actually know what I'm
talking about in
um yep I don't you know I don't have any
idea how to grow like in the middle of
Utah or Colorado somewhere where it's
cold so I like talking about zone 9
because it is specific to where I'm at
and um I've just dove into that because
that's what's been the most successful
for me and now YouTube I'm in California
um okay um Central Valley so
okay great great ranked second here with
the one month ago very great
so
um and then did you give do you give a
call to action to Something free in this
video
I think I only just bring up the I
showed the guide I think at some point
um I'm trying to think which photo yeah
but I tell at the end like throughout
the video I'll show like the guide that
I have and I kind of talk a little bit
about it but talk a little bit about it
and then at the end I think I mentioned
like you know the link to this guide is
in the description but I don't call I
don't think I call any attention to a
free guide okay so I mean the other
thing now that we've talked so much
about sales I I generally would
encourage that we don't really need to
sell on YouTube that the point of
YouTube would be to meet strangers meet
new people serve current subscribers
um and connect with them in such a way
as to
um
uh you know build that connection build
know like and trust and grow the channel
and I'll give you then one of my
favorite Frameworks that would be that I
would uh do to just multiply everything
that you're doing and it would be yeah
not to sell on your videos but to give
away Something Free and my favorite way
to actually do that that can
um affect the YouTube algorithm and
serve the people that are watching is I
do the same thing I do typically you you
could still by the way seed as you're
doing you could still see the book
because that's great so from the time
they meet you kind of seed it but the
problem with just even alluding to our
products is there does come a point as
you probably know in email marketing
it's where it kind of happens where like
people in a way don't know to buy until
you clearly articulate that like this is
for sale and here's how you buy it and a
lot of times sales is simply explaining
what it is what the process of checking
out is
ETC but saying that here would be the
framework I love to
um
have videos that have points and it
seems like with your chapters here you
have the same thing like you've got five
tips and what I love to do is create an
irresistible
lead magnet they'd be called that would
be the free gift
one question would be you already have
some but is there something that people
would love that you could give away for
free that
people would just they would love to pay
money for and they would love to take
action on that would vary specifically
like do you have a Zone nine lead magnet
I do so um the in it's very similar so
it's a free planting schedule which like
gives the date right great answer so we
have that already so so then what I
would do is in the video
I would
um let me come back to why I would put
the call to action to that in the middle
and then why at the end exactly what
you're doing here
like you're serving both YouTube and
building your email list and then
hopefully growing sales and growing your
channel so at the end of the video
we'll break it down so perfect video
recipe big idea hook content transition
transition is get that call to action to
another video if you had five points
you have a great hook good thumbnail
title and everything the beginning Point
number one point number two point number
three point number five I would
recommend actually basically being
another video rather than being a point
you explain it's a point you touch on
and you're like so Point number five is
and you already have these in your
library is such and such and such zone 9
gardening and actually if you want to
Deep dive on that click or tap the
screen and I'll see you in the next one
when we transition at the end we want to
transition fast so that we can increase
watch time
um avoid people dropping off have people
binge videos have people watch multiple
videos of ours okay fine so that's Point
number five so rather than potentially
like going super deep in point number
five this was five tips for Vegeta you
know then actually use that as a
transition Point like if it was plant
varieties that thrive if you had a video
on plant varieties that thrive you're
like you know some of the biggest plant
varieties that thrive are strawberries
garlic and lettuce but actually there's
10 of them and if you want to see my
video on all 10 click or tap the screen
my name is Audrey see you in the next
one smash like peace and then it's like
over and they and then it's just click
on that card okay so then mid video one
of the points is watering schedule right
and so you're like and so tip number
three is you really need to dial in your
watering schedule now I actually have a
guide that's totally free you could like
you know print it out if you want put it
on your refrigerator or whatever I'll
link to that in the description actually
has a whole watery schedule but here's
what it is and so weaving in an
articulated
pain point or solution that is your free
thing into one of your points mid-video
and
basically doing that every video is
would be my my dream of YouTube so then
fast forward if we kind of dial in the
fact that we are inviting people on our
email list but we're also doing in such
a way not it's not General it's very
specific and if it's a zone 9 download
then that's a very specific thing you're
going to attract those people that
either care or they don't
trying to do two things grow our email
list but also grow our YouTube channel
and I think that's the best way to do it
mid video brief call to action that is
connected to one of the points and your
free thing is a solution to that end of
the video they either already downloaded
it and kept watching or if they left
they're not there anyways but the goal
would be to just include increase that
view duration and then finally doing
that a thousand times you know or as
many videos as you're posting
um because as as we go to twenty
thousand Subs 50 000 subs and you've got
a hundred or two hundred videos in your
library that people are constantly
watching then there's constant new
awareness of people joining your email
list which is the best place for sales
to take place because now people have
stepped over that line to that next
level of trust with you some people just
want to hang out on the YouTube channel
great as ad revenue and all that stuff
goes up and maybe some lit they they'll
want to go deeper but the people that
that join on the email list and perhaps
they and also end up binging five of
your videos and so then it would just
also be a matter of if you use that kind
of formula or template
and you um
and then you do it repeatedly with as
good a video ideas as possible
eventually like or imagine if that call
to action was in this video the 287 000
one right eventually out of your next
100 videos then you've got like was
there one in this two-year-old one of
any kind I mean yeah so that one was the
first one I ever pitched the guide in so
that's where I think most organic sales
come from sales great and I'm saying in
this case I mean you could you could
pitch the guide but I'd be saying pitch
the free thing I guess it's kind of the
same difference because at least the
same direction but that also could be
the next 10 20 000 signups organically
on the other side of some great video
topics
um yeah would you pitch like on the
videos where I
quickly bring up the guide but I can
also always pitch the free planting
schedule which you do both in the same
video
no I mainly hit the free thing right uh
mainly maybe seed the guide not Pitch
you know like like do what you did hold
it up this is what I work from because
it becomes this iconic thing that
clearly people begin to see and
recognize
um but yeah mainly
uh being brief bright fun and done in
the video and and and and holding it or
teaching from it or something you know
it could be as simple as like you know
in the first sea of YouTube success is
courage I mean you gotta punch fear in
the face punch Perfection is in the face
like all I did was seed it no more call
to action than that and then perhaps
mid-video uh you know firstly is courage
you know the second C is clarity now
here's a couple thoughts about getting
clear on your channel but if you
actually want to download a free Clarity
guide uh there's a link in the
description down below you can fill that
out so anyways Clarity would be and then
putting that in the middle but getting
through the video because you still want
of course the average view duration and
all of that and so you're you're
building your business while also
building your YouTube channel yeah
yep
yep that's super helpful so there would
be no I guess um
because in all of my videos I could
always pitch one of my free sign up
guides so is that something that should
always be done or is there a point where
you want them obviously to get to the
end and go to the next video but
clicking a link in the description is
not necessarily bad I mean it's better
to get them on your email list than to
keep watching oh there's that fine line
uh yeah like you know uh Kyle who I know
you know well is the producer of think
media and like our our dream and our
vision is I'm like we don't always have
to include it in some cases we just said
what's the purpose of this video does it
actually fit would probably be the
number one question does it does it fit
without being forced and we love to make
videos that maybe have no call to action
of course Except watch another video at
the end they lead to some other video
but if it fits I think is a big key and
I would say that oftentimes it's more of
a it's more of an ongoing conversation
of to your point you deeply care about
your brand you care about your audience
you care about trust you don't want
there I do think there is such a thing
as like over pitching or over promotion
but to me I just like to crank up the
value as high as possible like the value
is so high the pitches if you are so
minimal compared compared to that value
so yeah do you have to in every video I
don't think so but will sometimes joke
if we didn't and then we look back we're
like great got 550 000 views like that
would have been nice if we would have
had a call to action in there a lot of
it is it's kind of like uh dating in
relationships in in a way and Merit like
you could overdo it like we live in Las
Vegas right and so you could overdo it
this happens maybe a lot where you like
meet someone you're like hey nice to
meet you you want to get married and I
suppose that happens there but it's a
little fast for most people so other
than that it's like hey nice to meet you
what's your name should we go on a date
maybe another date eventually get
engaged that's sort of what I think
about in business is sort of like
someone's just kind of on the outskirts
watching some of your videos
um wanting you know I don't want to give
you my contact information but over time
they trust you a little bit more and I
feel like email is getting engaged and
then purchasing a product is like
getting married but that is a journey if
it's healthy typically and it could be a
different pace for other people it may
be that Vegas speed where someone's like
clearly Audrey knows what she's talking
about I just met her I need the zone 9
thing and they go from like not knowing
you to getting married by your product
in literally five minutes others it
takes longer so it's kind of a dance and
sort of attention to be managed more
than a problem to be solved yeah that
makes sense
one other thing is we'll look at you
know vid IQ sponsor today's video and I
put in zone 9B gardening uh into the
daily ideas do any of these you've
probably made all these but maybe not
like so
uh how to grow plants in zone 9B Garden
the Pareto Principle for YouTube that's
kind of weird uh okay so how to grow
vegetables indoor uh regarding like a
pro
um how to garden in different zones how
to grow plants in zone 9B Garden these
are all pretty basic you've done all
these
um I've done them but not that exact
like video title so that's I guess a
question I sort of had was um at what
point because even though I have videos
that have a lot of those points is there
a certain point like in YouTube where
you even as long as you change up
something is it okay to do multiple
videos on essentially the same
topically cover different Search terms
but
change up your video slightly it's a
great question and I think that yes I
think that too many people are afraid of
repeating themselves I think the goal is
actually to say
is not to constantly try to say new
things the goal is to actually try to
sit to say the same things in new ways
yeah fresh angle fresh thumbnail fresh
title
fresh nuanced fresh season but to some
point you're the expert I would imagine
though that
you know the fundamentals of Zone 9A
gardening are somewhat consistent but
and and my favorite example of this
actually would be
Dave Ramsey like Dave Ramsey gets a lot
of critique he teaches finances teaches
people to cut up his credit card other
credit cards teaches people to get out
of debt he's been doing it for like 30
years he's been on the radio his YouTube
channel is getting 13 million views a
month his his live stream channel is
getting three million views a month
other personalities
a lot of critics and cynics will be like
Dave's information's not that good Dave
just repeats himself the same time
you're like of course he does there's
only seven baby steps like it's the same
baby steps there's like nothing even
really that new
but what's so funny about the critics
and the cynics is you're like Dave's
built an absolute Empire and he's
transforming millions of people's lives
so while someone on the sidelines could
critique and say it's too simple or
you're repeating yourself or whatever if
someone knows you're repeating yourself
you should say thank you if they comment
they are like didn't you already make
this video you should be like thank you
thanks for paying so much attention
because clearly you're a super fan but
the world is so much in need of good
information and there's so many more
people to reach that you want to be when
you have a topic like the fact like Zone
9B is your search term you should
triple how much you're talking about it
but then the key and like another what I
took was I took how to grow plants in
zone 9B garden and I threw it in the AI
title recommendations the key could be
to just find like fresh angles like
secrets to thriving in your Zone 9B
Garden perhaps a really fresh thumbnail
where you think about like kind of fresh
uh way of of Reinventing how your
thumbnails look a little bit now maybe
you got to be on brand but I was
thinking uh you gotta you know do your
own style but I was looking I always
like to study thumbnails I was looking
at Evan Carmichael's thumbnails and he's
got this kind of like this new
people-centered like a Galaxy behind
them and maybe this is you hire this out
like you you find somebody who uh could
help you with thumbnails or whatever but
imagine if you want to talk about it
switching up the look of things if you
know
Audrey's in the center slightly
airbrushed and there's a magical
superhero explosion of of abundant fruit
and vegetables around you
says do this you know what I mean it's
like a whole fresh take and then the
title is secrets of thriving in your
Zone 9B Garden
um or you know transform your and so
these was also just what are we talking
about we're talking about fresh
Innovation with kind of the titles the
thumbnails the hook but then the points
and this is really meta describing what
a lot of people that are super fans of
think media they might be like Sean
I swear you've made the same video a lot
of times so be like why would I why
would I say new things when the
principles that work you know so how
many there's a lot of tips on YouTube
but at some point like I shouldn't go be
making up new stuff you're just finding
new ways to package we'll end on this
you know I learned a big uh a big lesson
from toothpaste
and you know I'll go to Target
and I'll be looking at the toothpaste
style and I'm like Crest or Colgate and
I'll look at the label and it'll say new
and improved
first observation
there's actually no way for something to
be new and improved
because if if it's improved it means
it's old because if it's brand new it
can't be improved yet so actually the
new and improved statement is a lie like
that's already so it says new and
improved that's actually impossible but
what actually is it it's marketing
secondly are you actually saying the
toothpaste is new toothpaste hasn't
changed in a hundred years like there's
nothing actually new now admittedly like
there's probably some level of where
they need to have of course Integrity
with that and why is it new it's because
they added charcoal that's a big Trend
why is it new it's because they tweaked
one ingredient why is it new but what do
people unders that are marketing
products understand they understand that
people love novelty they love new so
when you can
take your you can add a module to your
zone now it's newly improved you're like
oh but is it improved and it is is it
new well it's the new version it's the
new look but everybody listen to this
that wants to sell something build
something you want to tap into that
because when we're shopping like we
would rather buy the new Colgate rather
than the old Colgate just because it's
something that we're into we love new
stuff new car smell new shoes we want
something that's new so all of that I
don't remember what my point was but I
guess my point is it was coming back to
just finding I think great content
creators
it's
it's not enough I think to just
repackage something and have it be stale
and old I think the goal is to actually
get fresh inspiration get get a new
illustration that that unlocks
understanding what it means to Garden in
zone 9B get a new illustration get a new
way of get a new story get a new way to
frame it get a new way to kind of
package it get a new way to put a
thumbnail on it get a new way to put a
title on it and then do that a thousand
times that's I think where the
Innovative channel that is a gardening
competitor where you will go beyond them
versus what they're doing and at the end
of the day
chances are you versus the other
gardening tips person
this could be pretty similar so the
difference like as far as what the
advice is the difference right is going
going to really come down to some of
that online marketing Mastery
understanding maybe some of the language
or creativity or packaging ultimately
we're looking for fresh creativity maybe
in the way that the video is structured
maybe in the way that you try something
a little bit different you're doing the
same thing because there's basic
information that people need but you are
packaging it in new ways has this been a
helpful conversation yeah super helpful
um is it okay fast one last question
yeah let's do it
um so I've been thinking I've never gone
live and I've not started a video
podcast yet and is there one that you'd
recommend first over the other like
YouTube podcasts versus YouTube lives
I think that some in some cases it's a
matter of testing
um and
uh I'll give you a couple tips adding
value to everyone here as well and I
know Dr Felix will be with you in just a
moment
um
uh smash like if you're learning
something today coffee with candle crew
I think that
one I would love to see
from you
how how much are you asking your
community questions not very often not
in the community tab so I have not um I
have posted you know a few things when I
think about it but it's not always top
of mind yeah so I would so so you're
asking me I want you to also ask them
yeah so so I would love for you to go
into a season and and your email list is
probably going to be a better place so I
think that 99 of content creators and
online business owners are business
owners miss out on the opportunity of
like basically customer and community
research and feedback
a series of open-ended questions on the
community tab as well as multiple choice
things on the community tab perhaps a
type form or Survey Monkey not even
perhaps do this a SurveyMonkey
um short survey using best practices is
a whole other thing you could study you
could look at the ask method book from
Ryan Levesque and we'll link that up too
that's really good his whole thing like
there's a certain Tipping Point of if
it's too long people won't do it so a
lot of times rather than one gigantic
survey it's nicer to keep it a little
more Consolidated but the opportunity
here is you know the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins the
amount of video ideas questions to
answer like you could probably also with
you could probably do a 30-day Sprint of
a video every day where it's just one
question one answer like and just
literally Gathering which nothing
special about them like all right so
such and such it's a community building
thing those very videos you would have
never thought to made it make it but
because they ask it and then the way you
title it though is with the VRA
expertise because just because they
asked it a certain way you title it in
such a way that's positioned to maybe be
a little bit more broad or to get views
and clicks all that to say is in
surveying your audience what I think it
could come down to is
ask
um what would you
two questions just to kind of see and it
also doesn't necessarily mean that's
exactly what you're going to do but
would you rather
do me do a a weekly live stream on the
channel or a podcast that you could
listen to here or elsewhere and then
it's like podcast or live stream and see
what people say and then if you were to
commit to a podcast you also might say
if if we were doing a a weekly podcast
on
uh you know about these topics
what do you what would you like best 20
minutes 40 minutes or hour-long
conversations would you like just me
sharing information or guests and so you
can also test with the content but I
think getting feedback who would you
like to see is there other people they
follow they may or may not and so I
think that both are super relevant I
think people would like to do live
streams to me the podcast is better
because it's more structured and it has
more replay value
in the sense of a live stream typically
is going to be more community building
but a podcast
can all is also a YouTube video that can
Rank and perform Super well
and and imagining and I am not your
target audience but imagining what it
might be like for the people you want to
reach I could see them with airpods in
you know doing their morning routines
implementing your stuff and having you
in their ears on the fact that you're
unlocking the audio side when you
distribute the video podcast and audio
so podcast makes a lot of sense but
without leaning too much on my opinion
um diving into what your audience thinks
surveying anyways because of the
feedback loop would be a huge takeaway I
think of today's convo of how powerful
that would be asking a lot more
questions and another easy one is do an
email blast and literally say reply and
all and I'm going to read every reply
and like like hey
um working on some new content and I'm
just curious like what are your biggest
challenges right now or do you have any
feedback from me I'm going to read every
reply
love you guys Audrey and ask people to
reply to the email and send it to 35 000
people and see what comes your way I
you'll probably be overwhelmed by how
much inspiration that triggers for you
um and ideas and creativity and then you
can Niche down this conversation about
launching something you like a podcast
about improving your current video ideas
or problems and then also about even
getting feedback on products how those
could be improved or better marketed
um we're going deep here but one of the
things that we also learn that improves
sales is the more actual language we get
from the people we serve and you've
probably studied this the better our
copy becomes when when we know exactly
the way that the person we're serving
would articulate their pain Point their
problem and when we make that the four
bullets like this Zone nine gardening
thing it will help you exactly the way
they would say it then they're like okay
did she just crawl inside of my mind
like is she reading I'm doing a training
I'm beginning in Charlotte this Friday
and one of my slides is uh on uh how
much this happens for think media
which is people say Sean are you reading
my mind are you reading my mind and I
could find like
30 comments in the last few months about
that and the way that we do that is
exactly what we're saying here
um because if we understand especially
through surveying uh people and so I I
was able to pull it up so I'm working on
this presentation have you been reading
my mind it's like you're reading my mind
it's almost like you read my mind
Jesus it's like you read my mind well
I'm Not Jesus and I'm not a psychic but
uh
uh and so this is this is also the dream
of VRA right is also like we're creating
videos and articulating those videos in
such a way that it's like we're crawling
inside of and so Community tab posts
like really doubling down on those so
anyways I think that both are a great
idea my ultimate answer would be you of
course you should go live and of course
you should launch a podcast but also
it's test and experiment and to kind of
find out I'm making some assumptions you
probably are too and you don't know
really until you test and you don't know
until you ask I could imagine your
community loving that they could
passively listen to your content while
doing things and and then you know I'm
you I probably have subscribed or
watched the think media podcast you
probably noticed and we can land the
plane here every episode of the think
media podcast is brought to you by
something
and 99 of them are brought to you by our
own stuff
so it sort of like becomes just culture
of it like value hook up front today's
episode is brought to you by a free
class we have or free download we have
and
one percent of the time do we ever sell
on a podcast directly and there are
times we do because there's times where
we also just want people to know right
then and there hey this offers ending
like right now we just are finishing a
challenge and our VRA fam is ending in
in like 12 hours so that's a certain
time when we might hit that
um but you know modeling that in your
community I think could be really
powerful so it's a good final question
there's a lot of tactics there
awesome well thank you so much this was
super helpful I appreciate you thanks so
much for being a part of our community
and inspired by everything you're doing
and I know a lot of people here learned
a lot today as well great thank you
all right coffee with candle that was a
a master class we went deep there but
that's what we get here when you're
sipping coffee let me know what you're
sipping on we're gonna have Dr Felix on
and then I'll hit some of your questions
I'm gonna look at my uh
my calendar for today as well
good it's uh more or less open and I do
need to finish my slides before
I get on a plane tomorrow morning fly to
North Carolina to arm conference in
Charlotte super excited about that but
uh we got Ryland out here with the
cranberry truffle smoothie sipping on Dr
Pepper Gabby good to see you
um and uh big shout out by the way it
speaking of VRA fam ending
um IRS our special offer for VRA fam
which is we're just finished up a
challenge we just did a class and just
so you know there is literally 13 hours
as of this exact moment if you happen to
be here live before the special offer
with the extra bonus and the YouTube
strategy class all ends
um midnight tonight August 2nd
um on the Pacific Standard time so just
heads up I know some a lot of you maybe
already jumped in you might be watching
this you don't even know what I'm
talking about the deadline is tonight
vrafam.com to get access at the special
pricing and special bonuses for our
signature YouTube course
vrafam.com if you are getting value
smash like I do have a bunch of starred
questions I'm going to get to those but
Dr Felix has been waiting patiently so I
want to wait uh bring up Dr Felix to the
show
brother how are you hello son thank you
thank you for uh being here because
um I really appreciate your job and your
training program is really great and I'm
I'm just enjoy this session with always
you answer a lot of questions that I
have so what is this it was great
awesome well man I'm so grateful for you
tell us a little bit about your YouTube
channel and what your question is today
okay
I'm a gynecologist I'm in YouTube since
2014.
but I think that my channel rocket in
2019 so I have almost five years
with great numbers but I my great
concern is doctors or most of us are
trained to serve and to give away our
knowledge without selling anything so
you're going to see that my numbers are
great
but my revenue from YouTube is
is
like a small channel so I'm not all of
these years I was like okay my my my job
or my goal is to serve people to uh give
them some health good knowledge because
in in social networks and internet you
you can find so bad and myth everything
is like so confused that doctors and
health
providers should be on the internet so
uh my my question is I I don't know if
I'm doing I'm doing uh uh the the things
in the right way just thinking only in
serving people
um made the community without getting a
revenue with my numbers this is the the
concern
awesome
um and so
one uh how many people are signed up for
your
s your channel memberships
okay I used to have a membership and I
reached I think I think that 60 60
people but due to uh I I six months ago
I get into the these social tokens and
I'm trying to bring all my people inside
an environment that is mine it's not
YouTube environment so now in in the
social talking membership I have 35 33
persons people in my in my own
environment
okay great so I mean a couple things and
then what language are you speaking in
your videos
Spanish so Spanish and is your
viewership
in Spain or worldwide or why worldwide I
think that uh in this month in June the
United States is the second country that
I gave views so I I have a question
because I saw I watched a video from
free media that the title was in Spanish
and the discretion wasn't even Spanish
but the video was in English so I I was
thinking how could you do that so it's
like so you watch the video I don't
think that was my video though you saw
no I think that it was something from
your uh for your your team but I speak a
little bit of English Portuguese uh
Catalan and Spanish so I can I can do
some things in other languages that
could bring me more more people
yes okay so I think that that probably
was somebody that stole our content
sorry I think I think if if there was a
video from Big media that ah no I I
don't think so I but it could be it
could be but I mean we've only done
English titles speaking English in our
videos oh so you do I go into city today
I don't I'm going to send you the link
because this was perfect for me but not
perfect for me I watched I watched the
video in English but the hook and the
the tiger was in Spanish so I was okay
yes send us the link um you know and
that is as a separate note for coffee
with candle crew to learn I mean one of
the big trends
um is
turning your content dubbing your
content into another language there are
AI tools that are people are trying to
develop but they seem to not really be
there yet and if you look at someone
like Mr Beast doing it he does it at a
great expense he has local voice actors
complete re-edits the changing of jokes
to local cultural references but he's
building like Mr Beast in Spanish or Mr
Beast and whatever other language you
bring up a good point it would be wise
for us I think to start like maybe a
Spanish think media and do it at that
level of Excellence others I think that
of just maybe with poor dubbing or
really basic low quality dubbing or some
AI is not it seems to have not really
got there yet
um I also just to be clear I would not
recommend doing any other language than
the language you've built here in
Spanish I I would keep well we teach we
definitely have made this video a few
times and we've had guests experts
affirm this point if you're doing a
YouTube channel you never want to upload
videos that your subscribers don't
subscribe for so if they subscribed
because the title was in Spanish and you
speak Spanish
yes then they you wouldn't want an
English video next even worse if you
uploaded a video in English and someone
subscribed and then they realized 99 of
your videos don't apply to them or they
can't understand them that would be a
problem so I say keep the channel one
language per channel the exception and I
don't even really want to say this but
the exception is if your audience was
bilingual but the problem is like what
percentage of people would be at that
level of being bilingual better would be
to segment the
um the language and so I would keep it
in Spanish keep that going
um and then have you
thought about doing affiliate marketing
at all
yes I have I have uh an Amazon page and
but I think that uh since I didn't take
George or via VIA VRA course I didn't
realize that I could do it so now I'm
just I'm starting to give some some
advice and do affiliate marketing with
my videos but at the beginning I didn't
know that it could be done you could be
doing this and selling in YouTube but I
I'm already I sell more in with my email
email list or or with my blog
your email list and blog
oh okay my my blog is Dr Phil
felixlugo.com but what do you sell like
what kind of products well um they
they'll contact me and I I give them
some some advice or in the email list I
I can send them some for example if I'm
if somebody contact me for a problem I
give them some uh treatment that could
buy out of the counter without any
prescription
or in my I work in uh in my office I
work in two good recognized
gynecological groups I give them some
links or my page and I'm selling more
this way than in my YouTube channel I'm
not I'm not too worried about selling in
my YouTube channel because otherwise I
didn't I I wouldn't be here because I
have uh 15 people watching me every day
and I'm just getting small revenue from
YouTube but I'm I'm a kind of jealous
because
I saw smaller channels leaving from
YouTube and I I guess how could I with
these numbers I'm I'm not leaving from
YouTube you know what I mean it's like
okay I'm dumb or I I I I'm doing the
things wrong because I haven't like more
or less 4
000 subscribers per month doing doing
nothing because I'm just rethinking I'm
retouching every every video that I have
with the knowledge that I I learned from
you
um I I need to tell your course and your
the video rank academies it's great to
to to have everything like done do this
do this do this and it's perfect for me
because I'm I'm a gynecologist I'm not a
producer you know every everything that
you see in my channel is is done by me
but I'm not a I I learn everything since
2014. imagine Amazon like always
learning something in YouTube in 2014
you're crazy yeah well I appreciate your
kind words and and here's what I would
recommend I think that number one one of
the things that you're facing as it
pertains it's you know again it sounds
like you're doing fine financially but
you do look at how big your numbers are
a quarter million subscribers 4 000 new
subscribers a month
when our audience depending on the
country the audience is in the language
they speak where they are that's going
to affect our RPMs and our cpms and
unfortunately
um you know in a personal finance Niche
let's say in America
um with English speaking perhaps with
like an older demographic watching if
you were getting half a million views a
month that could lead to like a few
thousand dollars USD
um right now you're getting you know
half a million views a month and do you
know your RPM off the top of your head
yes one dollar and a half yeah so so
personal finance you know think media is
like six I know people that's more like
9 or 12 or 13. so you if if literally
your your RPM was 13 this is only it's
not so what can we do about it but like
that would be 13 times what your current
Revenue per month is
um based on what it uh you know
if there were circumstances were
different that what does that mean well
that just leads us to the conclusion
that you already have that you would
need to monetize in other ways
the other challenge that you have is
when you've got an international
audience
or even you just cross one border
affiliate marketing can sometimes become
a little bit complex because the prices
of products the distribution of products
is different we certainly recommend
cameras and then someone's like I'm in
Canada or Mexico or India and they don't
have it or they have it but it's too
expensive
um and so that's just one of the
challenges with it saying that
if I was going to do affiliate marketing
at scale I would use something like
genius links now genius links does have
a cost but the powerful thing about
genius links is number one you you want
to sign up for literally every Amazon
store there is literally everyone so
like Germany Spain Italy Australia and
you sign up for all of them
internationally you get approved and so
you become an affiliate for every single
Amazon
um store then through genius links
there's only one Link in your
description but if somebody clicks it
it's going to know where they are and
it's actually going to take them to that
proper store that's going to increase
the likelihood of someone being able to
purchase a product even still though
there's such a there's a big Divergence
of products that are available and then
when I think about that I'm sure you're
already doing this but you know thinking
about health for uh females and it could
be supplements or it could be things
related to all these different stuff and
so
so then that could be the affiliate
marketing piece I think the final piece
though is it's the dream product for
almost any YouTube Creator is a digital
product
um because people could buy it
internationally and people
um
you know can
yes the currency might be different and
that's going to affect things but it you
know they could use PayPal they can use
and you avoid the shipping and all that
other stuff and so in that case
I will admit not every Niche though is
perfectly positioned to necessitate a
digital product like you have a lot of
free videos
my guess is it would be somewhat
challenging like not a lot of people
would probably want to buy an online
course from you or whatever but if we if
we explore that and we start thinking
about you know especially if you think
about business development I know my
wife has used different apps for
trapping tracking her cycle and whatnot
maybe you could be an affiliate for some
kind of a app for Women's Health that
has a very strong brand deal wise too I
mean it's that's a major deal like right
and if there was an app that could be a
brand sponsor they're like okay wow
you're reaching this massive Community
speaking Spanish so
you actually could be one brand deal
away from like doubling to Forex in your
finances because of the audience you've
built
and I do think about you know again
menstrual cycle
um apps uh and then
and thinking about
um so you know to think about different
countries my calendar spot on now is
there a way for you could you create one
could you buy one this might be like
could you acquire a company that's
already established and kind of tie that
into your channel that's interesting is
there something that's happening
International and I also wonder of like
uh
I mean
I I don't know how search this would be
but again you've got the audience but
the CPM is a little bit lower
um and or the RPM right and so I mean
I'm just looking up uh
menstrualcyclesupport.com
into a personal brand person here clay
uh has a
a 22 Dollar in the UK course another
idea you could have here and this was a
door your cycle bundle
another interesting thing is if you were
now they'd probably be other
there's two ways to earn money from like
an online course you could create your
own and sell it but that comes with its
own level of complexity uh perhaps if we
also could always check out for some
market research
um isn't just eating your way to freedom
from your period pain it's kind of
interesting so that's kind of a diet
hormonal Health thing that's interesting
uh weight loss stuff menstrual cycle
magic but the other way to do it is to
actually be an affiliate for digital
education so you've done two things you
know that somebody they could buy this
from anywhere in the world so that's
cool and then you could if somebody
maybe was an influencer meaning they
have some level of influence or some
level of they've created something cool
they're also a doctor of some kind you
could bring them on their shelf they
speak Spanish you could do a show or a
collaboration and say such and such has
this product and you could be an
affiliate and a lot of times people get
like 50 they'll give you 50 of their
digital product so to break down what
I'm describing here is let's say you did
a four-part series with Dr Wilma making
up the name with Dr Sabrina and Dr
Sabrina has this
um menstrual cycle course for like
uh as we describe you know something in
Spanish
um for adore your cycle and she'll split
at 50 50 with you that's very common and
you do these this educational series and
then let people know like hey she
actually if if you want to grab her
ebook audiobook and the bonuses and the
online yoga class that's what this is
um you know Link in the description down
below and then if that series also does
well and ranks so we talk about passive
income in video reggae Academy all the
time then you've created a new income
stream by the way without actually
creating your own online course but by
platforming someone else one of the
things that we do on the think media
podcast in terms of monetizing multiple
ways is if we have a guest on that has
something we can link to what they how
they serve people
um and earn money in the process and for
example
sometimes it's just something that's
maybe related to the core audience
so when we have my friend Chandler
Bolton from self-publishing school
a lot of people want to start a YouTube
channel that's why they follow us not
everybody wants to write a book but if
they do then they would click on a title
of like how to write a book or why
should I wrote a book is very you know
and
we can then educate for free let people
get a bunch of great information from
Chandler bolt and then we can let people
know about Chandler Bolt's product and
then we earn an affiliate commission and
I don't have to go make a course on how
to write a book I don't have to hire
coaches to help people coach through it
he's got all these different levels and
so that'd be kind of two different ways
to do it I think you could crank up
affiliate marketing with genius links I
think you know keep making great videos
you could work Channel memberships but I
actually as I'm verbal processing with
you I think that your most lucrative
opportunities could one be like a brand
deal or just a handful of brand deals
that want to reach your audience you
have no doubt about it created you have
a lot of influence with a very specific
demographic that the right Brands would
want to get in front of in my opinion
that's a six-figure multiple six figure
opportunity for example Landing one
sponsor at a six figure for like an
annual sponsorship like they sponsor
your channel and a certain number of
your videos
to the tune of you know this video is
brought to you by I think about like A1
athletic greens if there was something
related to like women's health
that just was ongoingly almost you're
not even launching your own product but
sponsoring with a brand kind of
partnering with a brand that really
supports Women's Health and hormonal
balance or something and then perhaps
creating your own digital product but
partnering with others and partnering is
kind of almost to kind of a strong word
doing a one-off interview doing one
collab with somebody that has something
again I think there needs to be language
alignment but in just a brief moment of
searching I was able to look up and and
and men's menstrual online courses might
not actually be there's a lot of topics
and you're the expert I definitely don't
know what I'm talking about here but as
far as you know you're the gynecologist
so what are some of the different things
I think doing some market research and
brainstorming around that could be
really interesting what are your
thoughts about some of those strategies
yes I'm I'm really yeah I I I really
want to to thank you because you are
giving you are supporting my idea to
have for example a media key to to show
to them to the uh to the industry and to
other people because it's uh when you
have a doctor maybe here in Europe on
Latin America do you have a doctor
talking and everybody thinks that you
should give them the the knowledge for
free this is like you are going to the
this is his job is his his soul
everything so I was thinking to my main
goal is I'm jewelry forcing it is to
keep growing my audience my my community
because this is this is the most
difficult thing to read you know I'm
really really happy that's why I'm not
in the rush to to get Revenue because my
revenue is my community
every time I I perform a life just for
uh answer question every week or every
two weeks and I don't need to I don't
need to uh let's say that get notified
for I don't I don't I don't show I don't
need to send emails or anything because
I'm going to have 60 person asking me
and and and I for example this is an
idea that I that I just did two weeks
ago I I create a ticket to in order to
have a fast answer because I was like
crazy answering every comment in YouTube
Tick Tock everything that's crazy is
this an affiliate link
yes this is what's a direct and and just
to sell the book is it actually or does
it just go directly to her book
yes but this is a kind of Affiliated
marketing news you know I she was on my
show
and that that was funny because nobody
here in Europe is is hard to find
doctors that talk good in in YouTube or
they are not they are not get used to
talking the with the camera so it was
like like at the beginning I need to fix
some things and then we pass through
Instagram because you you can find here
more Instagram and instagramers than
YouTube but the the the the thing that I
create was a flash answer ticket
for seven dollars
I create that the person who wants who
wants me to answer the comment on
YouTube they talk or email
receive and it's like an automated
answer if you want me to answer this in
this next hour just or three hours just
buy this ticket
but I create this this ticket thinking
that nobody was going to buy because
seven dollars is is like okay yes he's
going to answer me all the way and in
the last three weeks I I have sold
20 tickets it's like crazy because I was
like okay from three to Max from Mexico
one from the state and one from Atlanta
so I was like okay I can do it and I
need I need to tell this to everybody
that is watching this is this was an
idea that come from your VR Academy
course because
it was like surprising me this kind of
idea when you don't when you don't have
the knowledge that you can do it
you are not going to do because if you
never watched you never heard the idea I
just I was just I I mean the video
ranking Academy I think that it has five
months
so my numbers are
my numbers but I'm I'm starting to to to
think with the seminars and everything
I'm changing I'm just taking the time to
do a better video because my goal is to
reach the 1 million uh my my Jose that
my force is to have a great audience big
audience so I'm not one to waste time
selling things because if I have uh if I
can double my audience they they
interested the industry is going to come
with me so you know what I mean it's
like okay now I need to have a sponsor
two years ago not now because I have a
15 000 people watching me it's like okay
now I'm going to be seated thinking what
I want and increasing my audience
because it's that it's my my soul I
educate people I give everything away
and that's that's the way that I I
increase my my audience in YouTube is
just answer a question
well I'm so grateful for you and thanks
for coming on and congrats on all the
success I mean quarter million
subscribers 500 000 views a month it's
cool to hear about you know people
grabbing tickets for that thing you're
doing and all the value you've gotten
from our VRA Community uh I hope that
this convo has added some ideas I do
think there's some ways to monetize but
yeah exactly what you're doing is you
keep serving people and you keep growing
you keep putting out great videos
um then I think there's uh just much
more opportunity for you in the future
and I'm so grateful you're a part of our
community Dr Felix thank you very much
for the opportunity and I'm thankful for
your course too this is great
appreciate you thanks so much for coming
on coffee with Channel and uh friends
smash like if you're getting value I'm
going to do some rapid fire q a right
now
um but uh a quick tactic I mean one
thing to uh remind you just as far as
best practices and you know I was
noticing with Dr Felix as I went to his
live streams I saw that a month ago he
did have a guest on and he did have an
author on and he was mentioning that
this QR code is an affiliate link but I
think one opportunity just talking about
video optimization is I always want to
have a clickable affiliate Link in the
description and a preferably above the
fold so having a clickable link up here
so it's easy for people to get to that
there's no clickable link here so on
mobile or desktop if you're on mobile
too you'd be in trouble because you'd be
like watching this but like wanting to
scan the QR code I think you could
screenshot it and like tap your photo
but you want to remove friction in all
online marketing so
um if there was a clickable affiliate
link to her book perhaps you could buy
it internationally that becomes a
question the ebook and and if you use
something like genius links which does
have a cost to it but that would be
potentially an opportunity there and
even taking it a step further and
putting an affiliate Link in the pinned
comment so that it's even easier to
click it of course best practice this
was a repurposed like Tick Tock or
Instagram
um which is a great way to I mean you
get an extra 581 views from something
that was uh just over here anyways but
use something like stream yard
and you could create an interview show
and we talked to Audrey earlier she
could do um of course this is how we do
our podcast sometimes we get super fancy
when we're in Vegas at Anderson Studios
um but you know all summer long I'm here
in Seattle and uh I'm making I'm doing
everything from this battle station
right here of course it takes time to
build the battle station but using
something like stream yard a USB mic a
camera and you could bring on all kinds
of guests have a high level of quality
so really cool stuff that is happening
there also as a reminder you are hearing
Dr Felix talking about uh the VRA fam
um he's been a part of that for a few
months and it's inspiring because I
always love to hear obviously we have a
lot of English speaking channels but VRA
Works in um different languages so if
you're ready to master YouTube with our
YouTube course and coaching bundle if
you go to the vrafam.com or click the
link in the description we do have a
limited time offer and what's Limited
about that is two things one we're
actually offering lifetime access right
now but we just had a meeting with
Brooke and Brian and Mel lifetime access
to our program is going away it's not
going away if you've locked it in it's
going away because we're going to be
more like Netflix and Hulu where it's
reoccurring either just every month or
you'll pay annually the reason why is
because we keep updating it because we
have a faculty because we keep making it
better now that is happening this year
we're literally rolling out the timeline
and so this is the best time to join to
lock in lifetime access to lock in the
price is also changing as well and so
this is the best pricing it's the best
time to join but it's also there's a
couple exclusive bonuses including our
YouTube strategy class that will help
you put together a 90-day Sprint a
90-day plan
for getting results on YouTube and so
besides having video ranking Academy
which is a resource that will serve you
for the coming years
this YouTube strategy class no extra
charge is just a bonus we've added you
can see the details at vrafam.com
um it's going to help you really get
momentum over the next 90 days before I
do q a I want to also just encourage you
that no matter who you are whether in
VRA or not you getting ready right now
it's August 2nd you position yourself
right now is a big deal
um because Q4
is always the most lucrative opportunity
to have ranked videos because of online
shopping because of cyber monday Black
Friday and holiday shopping by just the
nature of the Year Revenue Rises across
Industries a lot of businesses like our
negative ultimately in their
profitability all year long and it's Q4
that things flip positive because that's
when the influx of money comes in if you
make the right videos
if you make the right videos right now
you learn how to rank videos right now
and you start setting up passive income
streams and clicks to affiliate links
then you can have an incredible like
really envisioning the next six months
you could have an incredible Q4 and then
build massive momentum going into next
year but that opportunity will only be
claimed by those who take action right
now
and I just mean take action and making
videos VRA is obviously a shortcut
that'll help you get there but you know
sure it's summer here in the US rest
take some time off do whatever you want
but those who hustle a little bit and
position
strategic videos right now are going to
be the ones that are positioned to
profit
in Q4 they'll have videos multiple
videos that are ranked getting views and
how could you do five could you do ten
could you have 30 videos out between now
and November 1st that are getting views
even if it's just a couple that are
ranked in Search and being suggested by
the YouTube algorithm that are connected
to ways of earning money
um this is a good time to be putting a
little bit of extra work and I don't
like I don't like to judge My Life by
The Harvest I'm reaping but by the seeds
that I'm sowing meaning what well I
don't have the growth yet Sean I don't
have the passive income yet I don't want
to judge My Life by The Harvest I'm
reaping but by the seeds that I'm sowing
every video is like a seed it's like a
seed you plant on YouTube that hopefully
grows into a tree that lives forever an
evergreen video that produces fruit and
shelter and shade and nourishment for
you and your family for weeks months and
years to come I have 10 year old videos
that are still producing fruit and I
planted those seeds though with the hard
work the research the seminar system so
anyways right now is a really good time
to be hustling thinking about your goals
thinking about your dreams go to the
lake go fishing do whatever but put in
some work in August August is like is a
real opportunity where a lot of people
just check out you can check in where a
lot of people just uh shrink back you
can go on offense I want to thank you
for the super chats uh to Shar and I
want to thank Kix TV thanks Sean for
everything I appreciate the 20 Super
Chat massive love and gratitude to char
though
he said how should I grow my YouTube
channel I I want to give you a good
answer
um said with absolute love and but it's
kind of it'll be kind of a coaching
answer first of all uh I don't know what
do I mean what I mean is like
uh without looking in your channel and
for time's sake you know that's that's
not what we use super chats for
um my answer for you is actually to ask
better questions I don't mean for that
to come off like intense but but like
how do I grow my YouTube channel well I
mean subscribe to think Media Watch our
videos type into the search bar on the
channel how to grow on YouTube for
general advice about growing on YouTube
we talk about it all day every day
um if you didn't watch the free class
that I did last night the replay is
available for a few more hours go to
tubemasterclass.com and you'll learn
about how to grow your YouTube channel
but look said with just love to
encourage you like when I'm what I mean
by ask better questions is like if I'm
gonna answer
um specific questions for you right now
like I need more data and context so if
you want better answers ask better
questions
and so how do I grow my YouTube channels
just super broad like what's the context
what's the niche what's what are you
trying to achieve what where have you
been getting stuck what and and notice
that again the more specific we can even
be with our questions the better I could
be with my answers so my
heartfelt answer to the question is
watch all of our content because we talk
about that all day that's general
information
um for some specific information follow
up with a lot more Nuance on the
question and we do have some other
questions that came in
um someone was asking I think earlier
we're talking about either education or
entertainment most channels fall into
that what about edutainment that's
always the dream if you can make
education entertaining then
um that is the language of culture
content public speaking YouTube videos
will always do better
if they include humor if they keep
people's attention if they're
interesting we've all been a part of
like corporate meetings that like the
person presents dry boring
um facts and figures and stats and
charts
and yes they educate but it's terrible
and then if you really get in front of a
good communicator they're gonna probably
storytell have some humor
um and they're going to make complex
things simple and they're gonna make the
information interesting
so education on a raw format is is good
combining education entertainment of
course is better that's a whole art form
it's very challenging but I very much
encourage you to lean into that that's
great I have a problem with editing
videos for YouTube can you please tell
me a free app
um iMovie if you can get a Mac is a good
one uh Da Vinci people love DaVinci
Resolve and they give you incredible
features on their free version on mobile
cap cut the free version is incredibly
powerful and I personally been I paid
for the premium one but I used a cap cut
the free version extensively for the
last few months on my phone
will Sean share some of his current
reads with the stream I've read and
learned so much from his past
recommendations current reads well for
business owners the hard thing about
hard things if you're aspiring to if
you're thinking I mean I hope everybody
is you know Jay-Z I'm not a businessman
I am a businessman
um I hope you're thinking like a
business owner but
for startup Founders thinking like a
business owner thinking about scaling a
business managing your profit and loss
and especially hiring a team training
and things like that the hard thing
about hard things is an incredible book
um
I think that uh this one has been really
great it's very Niche it is business
Proverbs daily wisdom for the workplace
I don't even know if it's available this
is like some classic I mean you can like
find it like used but uh it's pretty
great it's it's like a connected to a
proverb or a Bible verse is something
related to like a practical business
thing that one's been pretty good
um uh and then
those of those have been the main ones
there's a whole bunch on my wish list
I'm also just kind of like I'm going
through like a study of the Book of
Joshua and so that's been powerful
particularly because
I think Joshua for Business Leaders is
powerful like be strong and courageous
take territory be strategic
um all of those kinds of things that you
learn in there you know Moses is dead
it's time for you so it's the old
season's over it's time for you to rise
up and lead and uh thinking about why
did they get defeated a few times uh
because there was uh sin in the camp and
then when they rushed out ahead of God
and when they actually inquire to the
Lord and then followed God's plan and
you know be careful to meditate on this
book of the law when you do then you
will make your way prosperous you know
Joshua so that's a good uh Old Testament
book to be spending some time in Michael
says I know I've talked about it before
but it's hard finding time with two
young kids under four to find not to be
exhausted at the end of the day after
work and taking care of them any other
advice
it's a great question Michael
um one I think you got to be empathetic
to yourself
you got to know your season uh I mean
I'll be transparent about the season I'm
in and I have some incredible blessings
on the season I'm in and here's what I
mean
so
um talking about kids and time and
energy number one I'm a business owner
um we've got a big team we're doing very
well financially in our business so a
massive key is get a nanny like an
absolute huge key now you might go well
I can't afford that okay we'll talk
about something else in a second but I
was talking to it up here about the same
thing who also again
is doing pretty well financially and has
got another kid on the way and uh as I
got a kid and trying to balance home and
all this kind of stuff and I was like
what the heck are you doing not having a
nanny talking about travel and ambition
and how do I do it
um Dan Sullivan says this if you have
money
and you have a problem
or if you have a if you have a problem
and you have money you don't have a
problem
oh Sean money is not The Root of
Happiness well nobody said that Rebecca
like money's not it's it's actually you
know that it's actually a Bible verse
that says that that uh money solves all
things you didn't know that was in the
Bible
um
and Ecclesiastes 10 19. a feast is made
for laughter wine maketh Mary but money
is the answer for all things now of
course money is not like what fuel fills
our soul it's not the thing it doesn't
buy happiness but I figure if you you
know anyways uh ultimately
if you have so if your wife is stressed
you're stressed you don't you don't know
how to run a business and do a YouTube
channel and go to work and so on and so
forth and there's money sitting in the
bank
it's foolish to not
some people even get greedy with the
little money they have it's it says that
you value money more than you value
sanity or peace I will give up money for
sanity and peace
not only that you can also support other
people The Nanny involved or whatever so
for the busy entrepreneur it is it's you
got to build your team
and your team is going to also be your
family team it also has to do my wife is
the CFO of our business so we both work
in the business
we both
be for different tax ways and the ways
our salary is structured you know
whatever if I think about what is her
skill set allowing her to do the
finances versus hiring the nanny so
that's thing one but that might not be
as relevant right so
um that helps a little bit helps me
focus on work during the day us focus on
work during the day still I get the
exhausted thing uh caffeine is my tip
number two
let's check with the doctor uh and I
don't like to drink caffeine after my
coffee curfew but uh caffeine is is
honestly can be helpful and also I
usually won't drink caffeine after like
one or two in the afternoon but it does
maybe help me kind of about two cups of
coffee a day I've studied it in depth I
feel like I'm defending myself now
um but you know under 200 milligrams of
caffeine a day performance enhancing
drug no doubt about it generally healthy
good antioxidant I drink black coffee as
well whatever
um there's there's a thought but then I
also think just about you know being
gracious like doing the best because if
you if money is tight and if you're a
single parent if if you're working
multiple jobs like give yourself some
Grace and grace-based productivity is a
lens that you view life through knowing
that you are
um
doing the best you can with the time and
resources that you have now and then
number four is create some Leverage
like like for example in video ranking
Academy some people are like well I'm
super busy I'll join when I'm not busy
you'll always be busy like busy is the
best time because the sooner you create
a ranked video connected to a passive
income stream that builds up your side
income that allows you to buy Freedom
back like hiring a house cleaner or
hiring a landscaper or hiring a nanny or
going part-time at work is you know one
of the things that rock my world
was when I realized I was paying good
money to a nanny so I could take a nap
and I was like it would just be cheaper
if I just stayed up and then I started
to realize man my mental health my
physical health
the cost of a nap for me as a business
owner is looks like it's a little bit
more expensive than I would have
realized but then
uh any parent would probably agree a nap
is priceless like little enough sleep is
priceless so
the idea of when I was
struggling financially when Sony and I
were in debt when it was hard to juggle
everything
the reason I got so inspired and
obsessed and focused on ranking videos
and connecting them to passive income
streams is because I realized that that
was my bridge from struggling to Freedom
because I was like if I can create
compounding passive income
money answers everything at least in
terms of buying my time back money will
buy you an app and a nap answers
everything that's what that's what King
Solomon was saying it's like bro I mean
I mean your tired eyes really see a
bright future like what should you do if
you're tired
rest and so Ecclesiastes 10 19 Feast is
made for laughter wine makes the heart
Mary and money answers all things money
solves all things uh so many people are
offended and they don't even know their
Bibles But ultimately like I think that
um find a way
to buy your time back my friend Rory
vaden's productivity formula is do
things today that give you more time
tomorrow
uh procrastinate on purpose what things
can create leverage that's why YouTube's
the best platform that's why you should
ignore all the other social media
platforms at first because their content
feeds they'll burn you out
A ranked video you make it today and you
do if you're watching if you're just
joining you got to watch the master
class we just did on this very coffee
with Channel and save this video because
Audrey has set up digital products email
marketing
um and passive income streams she's
ranked by the way
she has a blog post ranking for zone 9
gardening which is the same psychology
it's the same business model as a ranked
video on YouTube people search on Google
find a pain Point find that she has a 37
product and she's making passive income
because of the leverage of a search
engine the same thing happens with
videos and so
that's even harder when you want to have
enough time for kids and building a side
hustle and going to work but my friend
and Michael want to speak to you like I
know it's it's hard but you paying the
price and you embracing hard right now
and you doing the tough things if you
live today like no one else you can live
and give like no one else later in life
and so build right now one brick at a
time the freedom to hire the nanny
delegate to the house cleaner take some
things off your plate
um and do your best to you know buy your
time back so you can rest and then B is
fully present with your kids as possible
it's a great conversation
um and definitely a challenge money buys
a nap and a nap solves everything that's
never I've never said that before but uh
it's kind of true and uh I I do it with
an immense Joy these days of sometimes
thinking that yeah money equals money
equals freedom uh I know Rebecca never
gets to defend herself you're right by
the way Rebecca is a fictional character
I need Kevin to chill
I need Stacy to stop being stupid I need
Rebecca to relax
those are three fictional characters if
your name is Stacy uh forgive me it
wasn't based at you I'm trying to rhyme
with like first names and try to make
things interesting all right we're gonna
land the plane here on a couple other
questions I appreciate you hanging with
me till this point Chris uh what's a
good practice to help communicate better
I'm mainly trying to to solve my ideas
because they're big and philosophical
but I'm trying to make them easier to
digest
Chris it's a big it's a big journey I
mean here's what I would tell you if you
want to become
if you want to become a better
communicator
step one make the conscious decision to
commit to becoming a better communicator
you're asking the question so it seems
like you've already done that but I made
the decision
around 2007 16 years ago that I want to
become a better Communicator step two
take action on that commitment
so what did I do I started to spend
money back to the whole theme of this
episode e to e ratio
I remember I bought a 12 CD set off eBay
on how to become a better Communicator
it had John Maxwell and Chris Weidner
some of the CDs were on vocabulary words
I remember I purchased that program I
purchased another program I bought as
many books as I could on how to be a
better Communicator like talk like Ted
and like Lincoln on leadership and these
different things
study I don't know what point we're on
tip number three study great
communicators study the best TED Talks
Of All Time study the best in your case
maybe people that are doing science or
psychology or making complex things
simple and analyze how they're
structuring their talks how are they
taking a complex scientific concept and
making it understandable for the
everyday individual number four practice
a lot the cool thing about starting a
YouTube channel is or a video podcast or
a live stream is even if you're not
growing yet use your season and
obscurity to prepare you for popularity
too many people give up too soon before
they've done 100 200 300 400 videos and
that might sound intimidating 400 videos
but think about it this way
who even cares if those videos were for
the viewer they were for your
opportunity to practice in public
who's going to be better the person who
practiced four times or the person who
practiced 400 times
the better Communicator is going to be
the person who's practiced 400 times
there was times when I was in Ministry
and I remember one of the aspirations of
like a hundred percent of the interns in
Ministry was they all wanted to preach
they all went on the microphone and they
all wanted to be on stage and we're
living in a world where I would
oftentimes question them and I remember
my friend in particular who wanted to
like I want to be a Bible teacher I want
the mic I want to be on stage why don't
they give me the mic and I asked him why
aren't you going live every day on
Facebook live and doing Bible teaching
well nobody shows up well who cares why
you're not going to like develop your
gift and hiddenness even though it's
public on Facebook or YouTube and the
reason I said like Facebook or Instagram
live or Snapchat is like if you hit go
live and you put yourself out there and
you don't just dabble but you're like
I'm gonna give a good opening I'm going
to give a good structure I'm going to
deliver this thing like the best way to
teach a preacher is to preach a preacher
I heard someone say once so well no
one's giving me the opportunity to get
on the platform we're living in 2023
anybody can press record and press go
live so if you want to become a better
Communicator you should do it a lot and
the really cool thing is we're living in
a world if you want to become an inner
better interviewer you should interview
a lot of people if you want to become a
better live streamer you should go live
a lot and one of the ways on top of my e
to e ratio of learning
um in addition to books and whatnot I
bought tickets to coaching events where
they help you speak on stage and become
a better communicator
and so e to e ratio meets practicing
meets add time to the equation and
perseverance and then that would be the
final thing then multiply that by time
and
it's 16 years later and I don't know if
I'm a good communicator or not I'm doing
my best I don't know if uh my skills of
being on camera have developed or
whatever I'm doing my best but wherever
whatever I've achieved today I've been
doing it for 16 plus years not
haphazardly but like Malcolm Gladwell
teaches deliberate practice of the 10
000 hour rule I've probably invested 30
to 40 000 hours in communication
practice and repetition deliberate
practice bonus tip number six if the
numbers are even right review the game
tape one of the biggest mistakes I see
people make is they don't review their
game tape the late great Kobe Bryant May
rest in power was famous for how much
game tape he'd watch whether they won
the basketball game or lost the
basketball game it was known that he
would get in front of the replay footage
and analyze the game for what he could
have done better no joke 99 of
entrepreneurs and content creators do
not review their game tape I heard one
person bragging about I I just like do
my thing and I don't even I don't even
go back and watch it I just let it be
out there they'll speak on stage they
don't watch the the recording of them
speaking on stage I'm like are you
insane
are you just an average loser I'm just
kidding but like like for real you're
like you're you have the arrogance or
the audacity to not go back to analyze
even if you won the game the greats go
into the locker room to say okay what
are the wins and takeaways what are the
losses what can we improve and so when
you watch back your game tape I'll admit
I had an advantage
bonus tip number seven I had an
advantage from 2000 and
four to two thousand and a long I mean
years probably all the way to 2015 as a
freelancer where I was a video editor
for communicators
you know Joel Osteen probably one of the
most prolific love him or hate him
communicators one of the most
influential can command audiences of
millions of people around the world
Phil stadiums
one of the ways he says he became such a
great communicator was he was the video
editor when his dad was the pastor
and he also had to take his dad's
45-minute sermons and edit them for TV
so they'd be 27 minutes
so he got to sit and listen to a good
communicator
but he also had to take something that
was 45 minutes and make it 27. so he
learned to trim the fluff and he
repeated it over and over and over again
so I got to freelance and I got to tip
bonus tip number eight uh proximity
principle get around great communicators
if you could go work for intern for yes
you can study from afar but I got to
work for Benny Perez who's getting
invited around the world to speak and I
got to travel with him and film a little
bit and then also edit clips for social
media I wasn't very intentional about my
career the places I went and the the
work that I did put me in positions
to develop
behind the camera to develop in the
number two spot to develop in the
assistant spot assisting somebody that
was doing something similar to what I
wanted to do one day speak write books
be on camera I was totally patient had
no rush to do it because being in that
Development season is the biggest
blessing of all time to be able to learn
absorb hone your skills sharpen your
skills Ken Coleman wrote a book about
this it's called the proximity principle
what is it you want to do someday go get
near it
you want to do something like think
media someday come work at think media
you want to be do a particular thing go
get a job or move near there or go
intern for or go do a project with or go
Apprentice for that individual so again
for what it's worth and I appreciate the
question
um those communication is clearly I I
had about eight points I'm going to turn
this into a podcast okay thank you uh as
I'm verbally processing with these I
don't even know if the numbers are right
but I'm doing my best
um as we spontaneously answer the
question if you want to improve as a
communicator there's a lot of
intentional things you could do multiply
all of that by time and repetition and I
really think that all of us can move the
needle forward to becoming better at
communication
um if you learn something today smash
like if you are grateful smash like if
you are
um not registered yet for VRA fam I want
you to know time is a short uh there's
less than 12 hours at this exact moment
until this deal closes not some weird
kind of false online scarcity or
anything this special offer with these
bonuses and all this stuff this is
ending at midnight Pacific Standard time
uh Wednesday August 2nd which is today
um if you're here live and you haven't
jumped in or you have questions let us
know I will say Irina said yep you hit
the nail on the head you can always
learn and improve by watching recordings
I just did a reel for Tony Robbins
challenge I hate seeing hearing myself
but I watched that several times thank
you Sean another thing Kyle you could
tell Audrey that I forgot to tell her
was that it'd be cool for her to do a
challenge
um I think it'd be interesting like a
seven day or a five day like grow your
garden challenge or something could be
an idea uh that as we were thinking
about ideas for her earlier
um and
appreciate you NZ uh think media podcast
always supports this is the coffee with
candle show the plan today was to do a
55 minute episode so I'm super pumped
that we hit that perfectly uh Ryland I
see your questions in idiot craft man
but we definitely got to land the plane
Kelly tags so save the date for the next
one how do I do that well we don't know
when it's gonna be but uh turn on
notifications subscribe and turn on
notifications coffee with candle goal is
to have it be a couple times a month if
not weekly and I'm super grateful for
you being a part of our community and uh
for smashing the like button and then if
you did just jump on
um
this is a good one
to uh to replay we got into some serious
tactics we really had an online business
master class with Audrey earlier and um
it's been a fun episode if you have any
ahas drop them if you have any feedback
drop it excuse me for burping into the
microphone that's gross but that's what
you get at the end here uh uh Bertrand
appreciate you grateful for you
um I'm using stream yard we can link to
a video of how I'm doing the picture in
picture and all that kind of stuff here
and then you can see uh if you're
watching on Facebook or YouTube
uh Dre I just dropped a link to
vrafam.com that is all ending so we do
want you to know that there is a legit
deadline happening uh Katja really
appreciates you thanks so much for being
here my friends this is the coffee with
Channel show my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel and I can't
wait to see you